-My first guest
is an Oscar winner
starring alongside
Denzel Washington and Jared Leto
in -- in the new film
"The Little Things,"
which will be in theaters
this Friday and on HBO Max.
Here is Rami Malek.
-What up, baby?!
-Rami Malek, hello and welcome
back to "The Tonight Show."
You're looking fantastic.
Look at this look.
You're pulling it off again.
Another look.
-I'm pulling off
another look, man.
-You know what's so weird?
Like, now -- I have kids now,
and I've never seen the
"Night at the Museum" movies.
And here you walk in,
and I go, "What?! What?!"
-Dude.
-It's the biggest thing.
My kids love you.
-Oh, Frannie and Winnie.
Give them my love.
-Yeah, dude. Exactly.
Oh, my gosh.
-The best part
of that experience
was, you know,
Ben was great to me.
-Yeah. Good.
-I'll tell you something
that nobody really knows,
is I was playing that role
so camp at first.
Maybe not "camp"
is the right word,
but I was going for it.
This guy was supposed to be
in a sarcophagus
at Cambridge University,
and I popped out of that coffin
and I played it
like a British dandy,
and the studio was like,
"Nuh-unh!"
-Did you really?
-And so -- Yeah.
And so I went back
to Los Angeles from Canada,
and I'm like, "I don't think
that went very well."
But Stiller and I got along
exceptionally well.
And he was laughing at a few
ad libs that I was throwing out,
so I was like,
"Something's telling me
that some part
of this went right,
but some part of it
went horribly wrong."
-Wow.
-'Cause I feel uncomfortable.
They're calling me back
for a makeup test.
My agent calls me and goes,
"There's a breakdown coming out
for this role again."
So I was like,
"I'm getting fired."
-That's not good.
-The only reason that I got back
and had to re-audition
was because Stiller said,
"Nah. I think you guys
are making a mistake here."
So that was one
super-cool thing.
The other great thing
was Robin Williams
for, you know, three movies --
-Yeah.
-And, sad,
but on the third one,
we're shooting
at the British Museum at night,
and we have the place
all to ourselves.
And Robin --
you could tell something
was happening with him, right?
He had -- He would go on these
riffs every once in a while
and light up the world,
and you'd be like,
"Oh, my God. Who are you?"
-"Who is this?"
-And then dip back down
into this other place.
He'd see us all
on our phones and devices,
and he'd be like,
"What happened to this?
What happened to this?"
And so I see him kind of veer
off, and he walks off alone,
and he's just kind of staring
at this massive rock
in the British Museum.
And I'm like, "Oh, man.
What's going on with him?
Is he all right?"
So I walk up to kind of say,
"Is everything okay?"
And he looks at me,
just kind of slightly
over the shoulder, and he goes,
"How often do you get to be
alone with the Rosetta Stone?"
-[Stammers]
That's the best story
I've ever heard in my life.
-Amazing right?
-Wow!
And you were like,
"Apparently not enough
because I just interrupted you."
[ Laughter ]
-It was so good.
-I always love talking to you.
The last time I talked to you,
we were at the Time 100.
And I don't know
if you remember. It was --
I mean, it was --
Every cool person was there.
It was actually
a really great night.
Nancy Pelosi --
You and I and Nancy Pelosi
hung out and took a photo.
-Well, yeah.
-Look at this.
Look how tan I was.
-It was so cool to hang out
with you there and her there.
And, you know, she was a fan
of "Bohemian Rhapsody."
I was like, "Well,
I'm a fan of you, Nancy."
-Yeah.
-But she dug the movie,
which was cool.
-You went on to win the Oscar.
You won the Academy Award.
-It was such a trip, man.
It was such a trip.
The coolest part is --
We had to keep it under wraps,
but Queen opened that night,
if you remember.
-Yes.
-And so you hear that music --
And because, you know,
I've spent almost two years
preparing for it --
I'm kind of instantly
brought back
to the first moment
of acknowledging
that I might play this man
and what that meant,
and so the whole thing
kind of came full circle,
and I had my mom there
and my brother and sister...
-No!
-So, for me, it's --
The statue is everything.
The experience just kind of
was overwhelming
for so many reasons.
Speaking of Mom, on Friday,
she's got
a very special birthday.
So, I love you, lady.
Happy birthday.
-Aww. Mom, we love you.
Look what you made.
What a great kid.
Look what you did.
Look what you made.
Brought into the world.
How cool is this guy?
-And to piggyback off of family,
I mean, you guys --
One, I just have to appreciate
what you've done with the show
given the circumstances, man.
It's been so intimate, and I
know we're talking to each other
as family and friends
often through this medium,
but to get to kind of have
these really intimate,
you know, thoughtful,
still very funny
but extremely personal
and fulfilling moments
with you every night
means a lot.
And, you know, you and --
At the beginning.
And Nancy and Winnie
and Frannie
getting on and putting
that together was just --
It was kind of healing
in a way, I got to say.
So thank you.
-Oh, my gosh.
I will tell everyone.
My kids love you, man.
They're obsessed.
They can't wait to see
"The Little Things."
-[ Laughing ]
-They're so excited.
They love murder whodunit crime
with three --
By the way, how about --
Adding to your list
of cool things,
you get to do a movie
with Denzel Washington.
-It's one of those moments,
you know --
I try not to go back to
the trailer to escape the set.
I'm like, "I'm with Denzel.
Ask him some questions."
-Anything.
-Ask him some questions.
And he gets a lot of questions.
He gets, you know,
the Oscar question a lot.
Like, "Where do you
keep your Oscar?"
And he made me laugh.
He said,
"Next to the other one."
-[ Laughs ]
-Which I found very amusing.
-Yeah. That's a great answer.
Oh, man.
-It was a good one.
-How do we describe the movie?
-I mean, I can give you
a long-winded answer,
but you know what it is?
It's this 1990s
psychological thriller
that feels like
a throwback movie
we've kind of been yearning for,
for so many years, right?
We don't see these movies often.
And it is gripping
to the very last second.
-It's awesome.
I want to show a clip.
Here is Rami Malek
and Denzel Washington
in "The Little Things."
Take a look.
[ Radio chatter ]
-Really. This is how
you spend your time off?
-What do you got?
-Deceased fits the M.O.
Stab wound, ligature,
killed elsewhere.
-She a floater?
-Yeah.
They dumped overflow in here
a few days back.
Guessing there's mud
in her cavities.
Shallow grave most likely.
♪♪
You ready to tell me
about Mary Roberts?
♪♪
Your boy Stan Peters swallowed
a 12-gauge late last night.
♪♪
-Rami Malek, everybody.
"The Little Things"
is in theaters this Friday
and available on HBO Max.
Thanks so much for coming on.
Always great to see you, buddy.
-It's a pleasure, man.
Thank you for everything.